a scalp to fill out and it if he ever
thought God it's the perfect rivalry the
baseline player and the net Russia in
Toledo offset
mr. borke how does it feel knowing you
who could make history of you when
you'll fit the bullet
[Music]
no special feelings just funny grown-up
the only thing standing between Borg and
that record is you
[Applause]
as different as two people could
possibly be busy backstage as someone
who's he liked a bigger talent but
playing Borg is like being hit by a
sledgehammer does the best
[Music]
you've added how do you spot your
comment
that woke the machine will soon break
down I'm just like anybody has a lot of
machine
there's not that much of Africa through
the anyway you don't understand what the
[ __ ] it takes to play tennis people you
know I go out there like if everything
for this game everything everything in
me gets left out on that [ __ ] court
and now do you understand because now
you do it
Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
don't do shelf
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]